est ce que cette redevance un top
dignité a justifié ou pas je sais pas
moi je lis chaque année les rappeurs des
producteurs de musique notamment qui
nous explique que aujourd'hui on est
dans une économie du flux ou la personne
physique va plutôt s'abonner à des
services comme spotify comme deezer com
youtube que son premier ou en accès
libre et j'ai beau faire un panorama
autour de moi je ne sais pas qui
aujourd'hui réalise des copies donc déjà
la redevance copie privée en elle-même
aux questions il serait bien qu'on est
une instance indépendante qui viennent
déterminer si oui ou non aujourd'hui on
a encore besoin d'un tel dispositif
ou encore un tel niveau de redevance
alors sur les biens reconditionnés alors
là ça veut travailler encore plus parce
que ce mécanisme là il est quand même
intervenu dans le cadre d'un d'une
proposition de loi destinée à verdir le
numérique à verdir le numérique et de
cette proposition de loi monde aboutit
finalement un mécanisme qui vient non
pas le verdir mais l'assujetti lille
rennes et donc une redevance qui est
ressenti comme une taxe par les
principaux acteurs de la volonté d'éric
autorails qu'un député elle même de la
majorité donc que de faire une espèce de
bilan un état des dieux une espèce de
remise à niveau du dispositif pour voir
un petit peu quels sont ses atouts mais
également ses défauts me semble faire
sens aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas c'est pas en tout cas
une mauvaise idée c'est ce qu'on peut on
peut dire c'est que effectivement la
question de la redevance autour de la
copie privée est un être une question
autour des droits d'usagé
si on reconditionne un support le
smartphones les tablettes etc
c'est qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle
utilisation est donc il y a quand même
beaucoup de cas lorsque des produits
sont réintroduits sur le marché sur
lesquels en fait il y as derrière ça des
possibilités de de mettre en place sur
les usages un droit alors là pour la
propriété intellectuelle de copies le
recyclage c'est 10 % des smartphones et
des tablettes
qui sont reconditionnés et enfin le lait
reconditionneurs ont quand même
manifester et ils s'associent a été tenu
compte puisque en fait la redevance est
calculé sur la marge
et cette marge en fait si c'est quand
même le consommateur qui est
l'utilisateur qui va la règle est donc
c'est pas le leur au conditionnel sur
son prix qui étaient pénalisés et
quelque part il faut aussi que les
auteurs
les ayants droit puissent bénéficier de
deux des copies 1 et qui se font il ya
quand même un droit de reproduction qui
doit être protégé la redevance copie
privée n'est pas déterminée en fonction
des marges des reconditionneurs c'est
pas du tout ça à des contres elle est
déterminée en fonction d'une étude
d'usagé l'étude usage pour consiste à
quoi ça consiste à prendre un panel
d'utilisateurs est à déterminer en
pratiques de copie cette étude d'usagé
réalisé au sein d'une commission
administrative de 24 membres
il y a en théorie tous vos doubles et
douze bénéficiaires les redevables da ce
sont les consommateurs et les
industriels qui ont chacun six sièges
respectivement
oui mais on est d'accord là dessus on
est d'accord là-dessus ce que vous
dégueulis la colère c'était les records
si vous permet d'être finir ça permettra
de finir et donc le set heureusement
cela est déterminant au sein d'une
commission copie privée et ce sont les
ayants droit qui finance ses études
usage en question aujourd'hui percevoir
8 europe face d'abord 14 euros puis
après 8 14 euros sur le neuf et ensuite
8h40 à chaque reconditionnement d'un
seul appareil
eh bien ça pose question et je ne sais
pas si c'est la meilleure modalités
qu'ils puissent être envisagés pour
soutenir ou verdir le numérique
parce qu'en l'occurrence là on ne leur
dit pas numérique ont ancré ont créé une
nouvelle manne pour les industries
culturelles au titre de copies qui est
qu'elles sont elles-mêmes évalué via des
études usage qu'elles sont elles même
financé au sein d'une commission
administrative où elles sont elles mêmes
en force
je trouve que ça fait beaucoup la
redevance sur la copie privée a toujours
fait débat
de tout temps il faut quand même ne pas
oublier une chose c'est que lorsque l'on
entre professionnels on n'a pas supporté
cette redevance pour la copie privée
donc ça touche les consommateurs donc
moi je trouve que le débat
il pourrait être au niveau des
consommateurs mais en même temps les
consommateurs veulent de la culture les
consommateurs ils veulent pouvoir aussi
bénéficié de pas mal davantage d' écoute
donc il ya quelque part il est
intéressant aussi qu' ils participent
aussi à cette culture l'industrie
numérique polluent énormément
et là on aura demain c'est peut-être à
prévoir aussi des redevances autour de
sa reconditionnés c'est remettre en
circulation et c'est permettre à
d'autres copistes de utiliser un droit d
usage
donc il faut si vous voulez à partir de
là considéré que ce droit d' usage et
bien il est monnayée ce qui est
l'intérêt c'est qu'une fois en six ans
la quitter eh bien on est tranquille et
on n'est pas contre facteurs donc tout
ça est aussi une garantie qui peut être
apportée voilà bon à la fin c'est
toujours le consommateur mais bon c'est
quand même lui aussi